[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW MOORE: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Thank you all so much for
joining us today and being
here at this year's
Next conference
and making time on a Friday
afternoon to fill the house.
We're extremely excited to
see all of you here today.
To introduce myself,
my name is Matt Moore,
and I'm the product manager
on the Google Cloud Jobs API,
which was launched in
Alpha this last November.
And today, I'm really excited
to talk to you about something
that I'm extremely passionate
about, which is job search.
But first of all, in this
session, what we're going to do
is we're going to take
a behind-the-scenes look
at the Jobs API.
We're going to provide
an update on what
we've been working on on the
API since our announcement
in November.
And we're extremely
excited to be joined today
by the head of talent
management at Johnson & Johnson
to hear about his
experiences deploying
the API to the Johnson
& Johnson career site.
First of all, what is the
Google Cloud Jobs API?
Well, obviously, it's the first
vertical pre-trained machine
learning model from Google.
That's clear.
Right?
But what does this really mean?
To answer that, let's
take a step back--
story time.
Here at Google, we started
with a simple question.
How could we create
a tenfold increase
in the number of
people that we hire?
We began by taking a deep
look at all of Google's hiring
channels.
And we found, to our surprise,
that the Google career
site, which you
see here, was one
of the most scalable
channels in that it
was severely under-utilized.
So after analyzing user
behaviors and interactions
on the career site,
we realized if we
were able to make even a small
change to the career site
conversion rate, we'd be
making a material difference
to the bottom line, to
the number of people
that we hired every year.
And so we looked
for opportunities
where we could optimize.
We ran countless experiments,
and we focused hard
on improving the career
site visitor experience,
looking for every way we could
drive an increase to conversion
and ultimately generate
high-quality hires.
The resulting solutions,
which are still
in use on the Google
career site today--
feel free to take a
look as we are hiring--
became the first version of
the Google Cloud Jobs API.
So I'd like to take
this opportunity
to introduce Christian Posse,
our chief data scientist, who
is here to talk
about the problems
we've seen along the way and
what we've done to solve them.
Please join me in welcoming
Christian to the stage.
CHRISTIAN POSSE: Hi, everyone.
Can you hear me?
So yes, let's take a second
just to talk about one
of the main problems that the
Jobs API is trying to tackle.
So as you know, there's no
external writing job postings.
So very often, what
we're seeing are
companies which are
struggling and using
some kind of internal
language for describing
job titles that may not
be of use to job seekers.
So you can see a few
of them up there.
They are real.
We have seen them
through the Jobs API.
They are not the
worst ones, and I'm
sure that if you
are in the industry,
you can come up
with weirder ones.
On the other hand, job
seekers do not have a PhD
in terminology, and so
they cannot anticipate all
the possible ways that a
title can be expressed.
So even if you are a
recovery and asset protection
specialist, you may never find
these rec and asset prot level
one jobs.
Because how on earth do you
know it's spelled this way?
So the Google Cloud Jobs API
is like a translation engine--
a Rosetta Stone, we
like to call it--
that helps match the
employer's interest
with a job seeker's interest.
So now if you are trying to
fill this rec and asset prot
level one position,
the API is going
to help you surface a job
to the job seekers which
are best suited for it.
By the way, the Rosetta
Stone, if you remember,
is a stone that was rediscovered
by the French in Egypt in 1799.
It contains three translations
of the same decree.
At the bottom, it's
in Ancient Greek.
It was known at the time.
The top one was Ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphs that were unknown.
And thanks to the
stone, 20 years later,
a French scholar was able
to translate or decipher
the hieroglyphs.
So I like to think about
the job seeker queries
like the Ancient Greek, who
kind of know what's going on.
You have the job posting
titles, who have no idea.
These are the hieroglyphs.
Essentially, the API
is the Rosetta Stone.
But the best way to fill a
problem is to see it in action.
So let's look at
the search behavior
on the previous version of
the Johnson & Johnson career
website.
And we're going to take
a very simple query,
like searching for an admin
assistant role in New York.
What could go wrong?
Well, if you look at the
results, it's a bit surprising.
They are all mismatches,
and there are
a couple of reasons for that.
The first one is the realization
that very often job titles
are the combinations of two
or three very generic terms.
Independently, each
term is very vague.
But when you put
them together, they
create a very specific meaning.
And this makes any keyword-based
search very challenging.
OK.
You saw that problem.
There are more issues.
One is that an admin
assistant is a supporting
role for senior positions.
So it will tend to be mentioned
in the job descriptions
of the more senior role.
And now you have
an increased risk
of returning the senior
role in the search
results for the admin
assistant query,
just because you had the
hit on the secondary role
in the job descriptions
for the senior role.
And it's what happens
here, essentially.
If you look here, all of these
drugs are for the seniors.
And by doing so, you're missing
the intent of the job seeker.
So the API is attacking
this issue and many others,
and we will see a bit
more in the future.
But how does it work?
So at the core of
the Google Cloud
Jobs APIs are data models
that encode our knowledge
about occupations, skills,
educations, locations,
companies, employment
type, and more.
What you're seeing here
is a visual representation
of one of our data models, which
is the title or occupation data
model.
So once again, just imagine that
you are at night and looking
in the sky.
Try to do that tonight, but
good luck in San Francisco.
There is a fog.
So go back home and
look at the sky.
Imagine that every star
you're looking at is a title.
Related titles are
close stars in the sky.
And like stars
concentrated in galaxies,
titles that belong to
the same job categories
will tend to
concentrate in clusters.
So if you look at our skies,
we have some exciting galaxies
here, like the accounting
and finance, or the business
operations, or the art
of fashions and design.
Each galaxy is made of
thousands of titles,
and we understand
around 250,000 titles.
Yes.
But much more
interesting is if you
look at the structure
within the galaxies.
There's a fine
structure that encodes
the type of similarities
between those titles.
OK.
So we are in the age
of space travel, right?
So maybe we can go visit
some of these stars.
You want to do that?
I don't even know why I'm
asking you, because in a way,
you don't have a choice.
Doors are closed.
So put your seat belts
on and enjoy the ride.
So let's look at the video.
So our journey is going to
start by visiting the business
development manager star.
So what we want to see with this
video is a couple of things.
I will tell you what
you would have visited.
So if you're in the business
development manager stars,
you're going to see that
in the neighborhood space
there are very small
nuances of that title.
Oh, thank you.
Finally, we're kicking off.
Excellent.
There we go.
We are in the advertising
and marketing galaxy.
So the first thing you can see
here in the close by space--
we are capturing
very small nuances,
like a business development
manager or it can be a business
development director.
So we have these nuances between
a manager and a director.
You have a business
development marketing manager.
We also capture a lot of
vertical video manager role,
like a government business
development manager,
IT development manager, or
retail business development
manager.
So those are small
nuances we capture.
But a business
development manager
can be also expressed
in many different ways,
like for example, a brand
development manager.
So we just visited
a nearby space.
We went a bit further.
And you can see here,
we exemplify a few more
alternatives of how a
business development
manager is being expressed.
It can be mentioned as a
director of brand strategy,
or a strategic planner, partner
relationship manager, even
a chief marketing officer or
an account marketing executive.
OK.
So now we're going
to switch, and we're
going to go to a far,
far away galaxy, which
happens to be the transportation
and logistic galaxy.
And we're going to visit a star
which is the truck driver star.
So it takes a little
while, because really we're
going to go across the universe.
There we go.
And look and see.
Again, we have tons of nuances
around the truck driver.
So in the nearby space, you
capture things like a delivery
driver, or a class-A CDL
driver, a 7.5-ton driver,
or things like car transporter,
or tow truck coordinator.
But the most important
thing to realize
is that there are
strong differences
between those roles.
For example, heavyweight and
lightweight truck driving
have very different
driving requirements,
in terms of driver license.
So you never want to return
heavyweight truck driver roles
to a lightweight
truck driver query,
because there's a mismatch.
Finally, we're going to go
into the admin assistant role
that we saw a bit
earlier, which happens
to be in the administrative
and office galaxy, which
is a good one.
Same pattern here.
You can see that we have
all the possible nuances.
So for example,
an admin assistant
can be a personal assistant, an
office assistant, a secretary,
administration
coordinator, and so on.
We again capture a
vertical admin assistant,
like faculty admin assistant
or store admin assistant.
We capture also different
seniority levels,
like senior admin assistant,
or admin assistant one, two,
or three.
OK.
So we're done with our space.
I hope you're not too dizzy.
But as you can see,
it was fast travel--
some hold-up at
the very beginning,
but we did this travel, and
we never spent quality time
at one of these stars.
So what we're going to do now is
take a break, take a vacation,
and revisit one of these stars--
the exciting business
development manager one--
and try to explore
it in more depth.
So what we said earlier
is we understand a lot
about this title.
The first thing is we understand
all the possible synonyms that
can be expressed,
especially also slang ones.
So if you are in
the biz dev world,
you may spell
something like bizdev
in one single word, where we
capture business development
in that case.
You can use abbreviations.
There, too, those are captured.
You just saw earlier,
we understand
a lot of the related roles.
We also have relationships
and strength of relationships
between those roles.
Those are captured.
Earlier you saw that this role
belongs to the advertising
and marketing galaxy,
but actually it
belongs to more
galaxies than that.
It also belongs to the sales
galaxy and the management
galaxy.
You want to capture all of
these facets of the diamond
that a business development
manager role is.
And all of these
relationships, we
have them with
confidence scores,
so you know the strength
of their relationships.
Finally, we also understand
what are the skills related
to that role.
And since we're talking
about the skills,
why don't we do a small, deep
dive into our skills ontology?
And we're going to use the
business development manager
role to exemplify what
we're trying to build.
So what you're seeing here
is a simplified snippet
of our skills data model related
to the business development
manager case.
So the first thing is if you are
a business development manager,
you must have business
development skills.
That's kind of a
duh moment, right?
But actually, it's
a critical one,
because at this point in
time we can start reasoning
about what it means.
Business development
skills-- it's
a collection of
different skills,
such as brand building,
finding business opportunities,
relationship building, sales
skills, strategy management
skills.
But if you have
this set of skills,
you'd better have good
communication and interpersonal
skills.
So what you're seeing
here is essentially
we have a graph of skills
with different types
of relationships, which are
encoded by the different types
of arrows here.
So some skills are
part of larger skills,
some skills are
collections of skills,
prerequisites of skills,
and some skills are
related to other skills.
For example, the business
development skills
are related to strategy
partnership development.
And more importantly, also we
understand the relationship
between occupations
skills and education.
So we did earlier the hop from
business development manager
to the business
development skills.
Business development belongs
to the larger business skills,
which is commonly associated
with an MBA degree, which
is included here.
OK.
So we talked about the
mismatch between job seekers
and employers.
We talked about all these
beautiful data models.
Well, how do we bridge the two?
And this is where machine
learning comes into play.
So essentially,
machine learning helps
us extract content on both sides
from the employer and the job
seeker and map the
content to the data
model with great accuracy.
Once we have done the
mapping, essentially we
can leverage Google
search technology
for retrieving and
ranking search results.
So here on the left,
you see the employer.
Whenever a job
posting is inserted
in the private tenant on
the Google Cloud platform,
we parse the job posting,
and we structure it.
So we're going to use now
natural language processing
and machine learning for
essentially building structure.
For example, the
first thing we do
is we automatically
segment the job description
into its main constituents,
which are responsibilities,
company descriptions,
requirements,
and other subsections.
We also extract two dozens of
what we call Nuggets, like,
for example, all the leaves--
parental leaves, sick
leaves, vacation.
We extract all the
benefits if they
are present on the job posting.
We extract things like shift
flexibility, life insurance,
401k, tuition reimbursement.
So we extract these data,
and we normalize them,
and we surface them.
We also extract and
normalize the skills
from the Requirements section.
Also something you saw
earlier-- we automatically
categorize the job
posting into one
of these broad job
categories, our galaxies
from a bit earlier.
So we created a very
large set of metadata
that we're going to
leverage in the search.
On the right side, you
see the job seeker.
So when the Jobs API gets
the job seeker query,
we do the same work.
We try to identify if there
is a title, employment
type, company, skills,
education, statement.
Pretty much anything
that moves, we
try to detect it
and normalize it,
so that we can now match to
the rich metadata of the job
posting we just talked about.
So maybe we can take a minute
to go visit one of these data
processes that we have
built. And the one example
maybe we can use is
our title standardizer.
As you know, job posting
titles are very, very noisy.
I think I will just
give you an example.
I think in the millions and
millions of job postings
that we have analyzed, we
find that actually the number
of unique strings that you
can extract in terms of titles
on job postings,
it's pretty much
just reduced your set by 75%.
So essentially, if you have
10 million job postings,
you end up with 2.5
million job titles
which are unique strings.
It's very noisy.
Why?
Because there are ads.
And so often you find
content that does not
describe the occupation.
You find things like location,
company name, employment type,
but you find things also
like advertising jargon--
needed, wanted, grand opening.
And sometimes you find
extremely useful information
like administrative
jargon, like a reference ID
on the job posting.
So the first thing that a Jobs
API does is clean up the mess.
And then we standardize
the remaining content.
So if you have acronyms,
abbreviations, we also
do contextual disambiguation.
And finally, also, we extract
the skills and specialties
from the job postings and
add that to the title.
At this point in time, we
built high-dimensional vector
representations of those titles.
The dimension of the vector
is essentially the terms
and expressions that
we have gathered
from the titles and the
skills extracted from millions
of job postings across
hundreds of thousands
of career websites.
So now we can use
machine learning.
At this point in time,
we built a classifier.
It's an ensemble
classifier that is
a collection of
natural-language-based
processing classifiers
and the neural nets.
And the classifier will attempt
at mapping the statement that
you are feeding it--
so this title string--
into zero, one, or more
occupations in our title data
model.
Why zero, you ask?
I'm glad you asked.
Well, Princess of Darkness--
it's a title we have seen.
And I use that all the
time, so not literal.
No, Princess of Darkness.
So unless you have
some extra information
that you have extracted from
a job posting, like skills,
we must be able to say, I have
no clue what to do with that.
On the other hand, very often,
especially on the query side,
especially also with the blue
collars and those skills,
you don't find very
specific titles.
Titles tend to be pretty vague.
So you must be able-- like
retail sales or team members
or I want to work
in warehousing.
You must be able to map
the query or the titles
to not a single node
into the ontology
but to a multitude of them.
And we do that with a
confidence score, which
means that whenever
we do the mapping,
we have a sense that
the mapping was done
without ambiguity-- or
maybe with some ambiguity,
and we take care of that
also in the search results.
So that concludes
our little, deep dive
into the title standardizer.
We have similar standardizers
for education, skills,
and others.
But I think at
this point in time
you're much more
excited to see how
these surface into the product.
So I'm going to
hand back to Matt
to see how our customers
are using the API today.
Thank you.
MATTHEW MOORE: All right.
Thank you, Christian.
So our goal is to bring
this next wave of computing
to the entire talent industry.
Fundamentally
changing how employers
are able to attract, connect
with, and retain talent,
job search, if you
think about it,
is just the first step
in this API's journey.
I mean, almost every business
starts their hiring processes
with job search.
And as we found,
once optimized, it's
a very powerful tool
in your hiring arsenal.
So by working with existing
independent software vendors
and job platforms, we aspire
to create turnkey access
to the API.
We want to provide a better
job search experience
for all employers
and candidates.
Because let's face it--
hiring the right people is one
of the most important things
your company needs to do.
To date we've announced two
core use cases, both of which
are running in a closed alpha
program in North America.
The first one is
powering job boards.
For the job board case,
we are pleased to share
that CareerBuilder is
nearing a production release,
and ongoing testing
and improvements
continue to date with Dice.com.
Our second and extremely
important use case
is powering talent networks
and company career sites.
We're also pleased to
announce for CareerBuilder
that they've brought
over 20 companies
online with the API in
their talent network,
including CIOX Health,
GameStop, and Lucas Group,
helping thousands of job seekers
find their next job going
forward.
Additionally, the Cloud
Jobs API continues
to power job search on the
Google and FedEx career sites.
And later this month,
Jibe will be onboarding
HealthSouth, the largest owner
and operator of inpatient rehab
hospitals in the United
States, and Eaton,
a multinational power
management company.
Specifically for Google and
our online hiring efforts,
our career site handles several
million queries each month.
And we've seen a 28% increase
in candidate success rate
from apply to hire since our
journey with the API began.
And last but definitely
not least, we're
pleased to be joined
here today by one
of our newly onboarded
customers, Johnson & Johnson.
So please join me in
welcoming up to the stage
Sjoerd Gehring,
Global Vice President
of Talent Acquisition at Johnson
& Johnson, and Joe Essenfeld,
CEO and founder of Jibe.
Welcome up.
[APPLAUSE]
Come on.
There we go.
All right.
Thanks for joining us
here today, guys, and it's
great to have both of you here
to talk about the Jobs API.
So, Sjoerd, I was wondering
to kind of start us off,
could you talk a little bit
about Johnson & Johnson's
hiring processes and some
of the challenges you face?
SJOERD GEHRING:
Absolutely, Matt,
and it's a pleasure
to be here today.
At Johnson & Johnson, we fill
about 25,000 positions a year.
And as a company, we have
a goal in the next decades
to find a cure for cancer.
So we're heavily investing in
our oncology and hematology
businesses.
Currently, we have approximately
350 roles open today
in the oncology and
hematology space,
primarily in the
research and development,
and various commercial roles.
Given the fact that these
roles are so niche and so
hard to fill, we're
having a real issue
filling these positions
simply because we're tapping
into a very small talent pool.
And our current
approach is really not
getting us to the hiring goals
that we need fast enough,
so we're always looking for
innovations related to job
search and hiring practices.
MATTHEW MOORE: Wow.
So you know, when you first
started chatting with Joe
about the machine
learning and the API,
what was it that
caught your attention
as a possible way you
could use this to solve
some of those challenges?
SJOERD GEHRING: Yeah.
We've been interested in
machine learning for a few years
now, really because
we believe that it
can enable us to much better
identify and hire talent
faster.
And one of the things that we
need to do a much better job of
is to proactively
identify and match
people with the skills and
interest in the oncology space
to our various open positions.
And we feel that the
Jobs API can actually
make a real difference here.
MATTHEW MOORE:
And I understand--
I may have had a previous look--
that you and Joe have
brought some examples
to share with us today.
SJOERD GEHRING: We have.
So we prepared three different
examples for the audience
today.
The first one is a search query
around oncological research
and in the location
the United States.
And what you see on the
left side of this slide
is our previous keyword-based
search technology.
And on the right side you see
an example using Google search.
And as you can imagine,
on the left side,
a job seeker would
actually be quite
discouraged having searched
for oncological research
and not seeing any
oncology-specific positions
in the top search results
that the search yielded.
On the right-hand side, where
you see our Google search
results, is that Google
search is actually
using the understanding
of language
to return much
more relevant jobs,
even when it doesn't use the
exact keyword in these jobs.
The other thing that
you see in this result
is that the Google
search yields fewer
and much more
quality and relevant
search results over the before
picture, which really saves job
seekers quite a bit of time.
The second example is
around a search query
around microbiologists.
And what you see here is
that although the first two
examples are pretty similar,
further down in the list
you start again to see Google
search returning much more
relevant job search
results for job seekers.
And last but not least,
the third example
here is around internships
in New York City.
We get an enormous amount
of job search queries
around internships with
J&J. And I actually
thought this was a particularly
interesting example, because
in the before
picture you see four
results in the search, three of
which aren't really relevant.
And the after picture there,
11 relevant internship
results in the New
York City area--
much more relevant for
job seekers, again,
using Google search.
MATTHEW MOORE: Yes.
First of all, thank you so
much for being here and sharing
these examples with us.
We're really excited to
continue to work with you
as you move forward with hiring.
So, Joe, just having
heard from Sjoerd, could
you maybe tell us a little
bit about the API onboarding
process with Johnson & Johnson?
JOE ESSENFELD: J&J
was the second company
to be onboarded on the API,
and Jibe powers career sites.
So when we're going
into production
with jobs for a global
company like J&J,
one of our concerns
are, how do you
deal with that with a
closed alpha program?
You're putting
jobs in production.
You're handling this big
responsibility of hiring.
And with collaboration
with Google,
we were able to successfully
put in place some measures
to make sure that even though
it was an alpha program,
we had a successful launch.
One of the things that
we found very helpful
was actually having a customer
success function installed
in this early-adoption program.
So as we launched these jobs,
and J&J being the second one,
we were able to do it
about three times faster.
So we got J&J live, from the
time we got the thumbs up,
in about a week.
And going forward, we now
have a turnkey interface
that any existing Jibe client
can be live on this API
in under a day and
can begin testing.
So it really gives us
the space to do that.
But beyond that quick
turnaround time,
we were able to actually
interface and make
sure that the job families,
the job descriptions, the job
application process,
were all maintained,
and we could maximize that
value of that machine learning
process and not have to
worry about production issues
with such a young API.
So it went very smoothly,
and we're two for two so far.
MATTHEW MOORE: We hope
that trend continues.
JOE ESSENFELD: Absolutely.
MATTHEW MOORE: As you brought
Johnson & Johnson and more
companies going forward
online, has there
been anything that surprised
you about hiring or the API
in general?
JOE ESSENFELD: Yeah.
I think there were
two things, really,
with J&J that were surprising.
The first one was how
important location search is.
We were very focused
on understanding
this story and the benefit
behind machine learning,
talking about the
translation, and looking
at the relevance
of search results
like Sjoerd shared about
oncological research
and microbiology.
But when we started really
analyzing the query data,
we noticed how often job
seekers searched for location.
They searched for location
in the keyword field.
in the location field.
And the lift that
we saw-- at Jibe,
we pride ourselves on having
good products all around,
but our location search
didn't match Google's at all.
It was more based on radius.
And being from Manhattan
and working there, you know,
when you do a radius search
for a job in Manhattan,
you end up with
suggestions in Hoboken,
and Jersey City, and Queens.
And no offense to those
places, but people typically
don't want to work there
when they're searching
for a job in Manhattan.
So we saw some great
lift with location alone
and also the ability of the
API to parse out the results
in the keyword field.
So job seekers don't like
following directions.
And when we looked
at the data, we
saw the keyword field
was just polluted
with all this information.
And the machine learning API was
able to parse that out, return
intelligent results back,
and improve conversion
when we had that.
So that was the
first surprise there.
And then the second,
which was really funny,
was this emotional
connection that people
had understanding that
machine learning was
powering the search.
At first, it was
trying to debunk it.
Oh, I'm going to
find the query that's
going to show this
thing doesn't work.
And then they're
pounding the API.
They're looking for results.
And then what they find
is how well it works,
and they start to
understand that it's not
about keyword
search, but it really
goes back to Christian's
example about translation.
And a good example was a query
that someone put in for SQL.
So they were looking for
jobs related to that.
And the first result that came
back-- and this wasn't for J&J,
it was for another client on the
API-- was an HR admin position.
And they're like, oh, I got it.
We found that this didn't work.
And as they clicked
into the job,
it wasn't in a
database category,
wasn't in an IT category,
but at the bottom of the job
description it mentioned
how important it was
about pulling reports from SQL.
So this was a great example
of how that keyword actually
surfaced the skills
required for that job.
And that person
switched, at that point,
from trying to debunk
it to then trying
to find more examples of how
this machine learning really
worked.
So those are two
great surprises as we
implemented this and went live.
MATTHEW MOORE: Awesome.
We always love creating
more believers in it,
so thanks for sharing.
In the last few minutes
we have here on the stage,
is there anything
else you might want
to share with folks
in the audience who
would be interested in improving
their hiring process and talent
search?
JOE ESSENFELD: Sure.
I think one thing that's
really important to think about
is job seekers as consumers.
When they're on a
company's career site,
that is when they're
the most engaged.
And it really has to be
like any other transaction
on an e-commerce site or any
other consumer-facing site.
And when you think
about machine learning,
it's important to think about
it in that consumer frame.
So we want to find
the positions that
are most strategic to
fill and understand
how that translation of what
those job titles and job
descriptions are are really
relevant to those job seekers.
So I'd say take a step back.
Don't think about quantity and
just filling your pipeline,
but what's meaningful
to your company
and how does that translation
through your machine learning
really help improve
your conversion.
And when you start thinking
about it in that context,
you get a lot more
support and understanding
inside the
organization about how
to consumerize that
experience for job seekers
and really improve
candidate experience.
MATTHEW MOORE: Awesome.
Well, again, thank you very
much for both joining us today
and for being an
excellent partner
through this alpha program
and hopefully beyond.
In short, thank you so
much for taking the time
to share your vision both for
Johnson & Johnson and the API
today.
It's been great working
with both of you,
and we hope to continue
it going forward.
Thank you very much.
SJOERD GEHRING: Thanks, Matt.
JOE ESSENFELD: Thank you.
Great.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW MOORE: All right.
So I'm sure you're all excited
to see what's next for the API.
And today, we're pleased
to announce several updates
to the alpha and share with
you some of our future plans
for the API.
We've been hard at work these
past few months evolving
the Jobs API to address
additional customer needs
and prepare the API for
broader adoption, which I'm
sure you're all interested in.
So first of all, we've
added featured jobs,
which enables a hiring
company to promote jobs
that it has a
business-critical need
to fill as soon as possible and
be seen by as many job seekers
as they can get it in front of.
Secondly, we've
added histogramming,
which is the ability to include
and render dynamic search
counts alongside
your filters, which
is going to greatly improve
the understandability
of your search results
and experience.
Next, we've added support
for bulk operations.
Bulk operations allows you to
send multiple creates, updates,
or deletes in the
same call, which
is a much requested
and extremely useful
feature when you're
managing a lot of job data
like many of our customers do.
And finally, we've
added significant
relevance-thresholding
improvements
further ensuring our objective
to return great matches
for all job seeker
queries and showcase
the search quality of the API.
But now let's take a look
at what's coming next.
So in the first
quarter of this year,
we'll be rolling out
some important changes
and enhancements to the API.
To start, we're going to
be making improvements
to how we handle locations
in your job data,
improving our
support for both jobs
without locations,
which happens, and jobs
with many locations.
This quarter, we're also going
to be introducing integrations
for behavioral
data, improvements
to our existing data
models, which will further
improve your search results.
Looking forward, this
half of the year,
we're aiming to graduate our API
into beta, expanding and making
the API prepared for
greater public availability.
With the beta launch,
we're also aiming
to release a couple
of cool new features,
such as commute
search, which we're
going to talk about
more in a moment,
and job-to-job recommendations,
improving on our models, which
will build smarter associations
between jobs in the system.
And finally, as we
look to the future,
we've got an ambitious
set of goals for the API
to bring and expand the
API to customers worldwide,
translating and localizing in
new countries and languages.
And while we started
with job search,
our goal is to take this
machine learning-powered API
to the next level and enable
job-to-person recommendations,
helping generate smart
job recommendations based
on resumes and profiles, so
your job seekers never even
have to search.
Because search-- it's not always
the right tool for the job.
It's limited to being
initiated by the job seeker.
And this next step will
move the API forward,
leveraging machine learning
to intelligently match
job seekers with your
company's open opportunities.
But let's take a moment
and dive into one
of the features that I'm
extremely excited today
to reveal for the
first time, which
is the ability to search
jobs by how long it
takes to commute to work.
So as a little
background, it's been
shown that an employee's
commute has one of the strongest
ties to job satisfaction.
And when you're trying to
attract and retain the best
talent, employees
need to be satisfied
with all aspects of their
job, including how long it
takes to get to work.
There are many job
seekers that depend
on the availability of
timely public transportation
to get to work.
A job that's 20 miles away
may take over two hours
to get to by bus, which
is time that could be
spent at home with your family.
An employee that has to spend
two hours commuting every day
is probably going to
be an attrition risk.
And even for drivers,
job search until now
has been entirely straight
line distance-based.
And that's useful
if you can afford
to fly to work every day.
Most job seekers don't have that
luxury or a straight-line route
to work.
And when you're commuting
during normal business hours,
there's something that slows
you down even further, which
is traffic.
I'm sure you're all
familiar with it.
With commute time
search we're aiming
to help job seekers make
informed decisions around where
their next job is located and
be happier, more effective
employees.
Let's take a look at the demo
and pray the internet works.
All right.
So we've loaded up this
quick demo running on the API
to demonstrate how you might
use the API to allow job seekers
to search by commute time.
On the right, you'll see the
browser developer console,
which is showing the
real-time API output.
And we've loaded this instance
up with some test data
for software
engineering positions,
where you can specify
a street address, which
is Sunnyvale in this case,
a method of transportation,
which is either public
transit, walking, or driving--
and we'll pick driving here--
and the amount of time
you're willing to commute,
which we'll leave at 30
minutes in this case.
When we search, we can
see the API returns jobs
that have street
addresses specifically
reachable within 30 minutes,
as indicated by the blue area
on the map.
And as you can see, for
this job in particular
we were able to identify
the company's street address
and determine that this job
is 28 minutes away in traffic.
To take a look at
another quick example,
let's search from an address
in the city of San Francisco--
say, the downtown area,
where we all are right now.
And because I'm
commuting from the city,
I'm more interested in
public transit options.
And I live in San Francisco.
I have a high
tolerance for commute--
say, 60 minutes or so.
When I search, I can see the
extremely non-polygonal set
of locations, where we return
jobs which are influenced
by local public
transport options--
BART, which takes you up through
Walnut Creek, and Caltrain,
which takes you down
into the peninsula.
And we can get an accurate
and specific understanding
of where I can reach in an
hour from the city, which
is very important if I don't
have a car, for example.
You know, this is
a brand new way
of representing location-based
job search, one that's
more reflective of the actual
experience of traveling
between home and work.
Sorry, just jumping
back to the slides here.
We're excited to share
this with you today,
and that's your sneak peek
at the future of the Jobs
API, which you can look
forward to seeing more about
in the next couple of months.
We hope you enjoyed this first
look at this brand new feature,
and we're excited to be making
this available to our customers
going forward in
the near future.
And we really can't wait to
see what awesome stuff they
bring to the table with them.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You're probably all
wondering at this point
how to get started
with the Jobs API.
If you manage a
company's career site--
and we already have a number of
approved reseller integrations
in place at this time--
we recommend you contact your
applicant tracking system
or career site provider to ask
about leveraging the Jobs API.
And if they're not
already a reseller,
encourage them to sign up with
Google at the website you see
here, cloud.google.com/jobs-API.
For anyone here that runs an
applicant tracking system,
or is a career site
provider, or a job board,
or any other business interested
in leveraging the API,
please also visit
cloud.google.com/jobs-API
to register your
interest in the service,
and we'll get back
to you shortly.
Our API is still in alpha.
And once we've granted
you access, getting
started with the API is
as simple as setting up
a new project in the
Cloud developer console
and registering your
account with our service.
[MUSIC PLAYING]